simply
you're in a situation where someone
wants to hurt you and they are better
than you there's more of them quite
possibly they're armed they're bigger
all the stuff they're they're better
they're better at fighting than you
could be at fighting and so because
could be at fighting what are you going
to do
hi guys christopher hine here i want to
take a second to talk to you about where
i'm headed with aikido and what my
aikido is doing right now and what i'm
doing in my school my school's actually
getting ready to go through a ton of
remodeling changes to help facilitate
the new structure
through which i'm taking aikido so all
of this will change very soon and you
probably can't tell but we've already
got some painting done all kinds of
things are going on so
um
what i'm trying to do is
understand aikido from the perspective
of someone who doesn't necessarily care
about aikido
my whole martial arts career my whole
aikido career up to this point has been
about understanding what aikido is from
the perspective of someone who knows the
system of aikido so i learned the system
of aikido a number of years ago and then
i spent a long time trying to understand
what that system was doing so how did
that system work
through this of course i discovered the
concept of context and i realized that
there was a context that aikido was
trying to answer and once i found what
the context was then all of a sudden all
the techniques in aikido just made sense
and and you could see them from a very
practical standpoint as to why they
exist and nothing seemed crazy or extra
and i've spent my career as a teacher
mostly trying to convey the system of
aikido and then at the same time convey
how the context works
however my approach
up to
this date is kind of clunky when you're
trying to understand it from the
perspective of someone who doesn't care
about aikido so if someone has no aikido
training
it's a clunky way to explain as i've
continued teaching i really would like
to be able to teach someone who doesn't
necessarily have any interest in aikido
but they're just interested in solving a
particular context and that context is
the same context that aikido has and the
context is simply you're in a situation
where someone wants to hurt you and they
are better than you there's more of them
quite possibly they're armed they're
bigger all the stuff they're they're
better they're better at fighting than
you could be at fighting and so because
they're better at fighting than you
could be at fighting what are you going
to do
now the answer of course is you're not
going to fight them but what are the
other options that are on the table for
you in a women's self-defense class the
people coming to me don't really care
about learning aikido they don't really
care about learning to wrestle or box or
anything particular they don't have any
set designs on that all they want to
know about is what do i do when someone
bigger than me wants to hurt me or my
family what do i do you know and so if
you're a boxing coach well the answer is
to punch him and i'm gonna show you how
to punch as hard as possible and then if
you ask the boxing coach you know well
is this woman with six months of
training who weighs 110 pounds really
capable of stopping a 200 pound criminal
career criminal from doing something and
like the answer is like well no of
course not you know and then you ask you
know would she ever be able to the way
martial artists try and get away from
this is we go well if they were so
skilled but you know even the gracies
say you know for every belt you can give
up about 10 pounds of physicality so
even a black belt really only has about
50 pounds of physical advantage in their
skill and so it's like if someone over
50 pounds is an athletic wants to fight
you
they're going to give you a really hard
situation right and that's not even
including contexts where you don't end
up on the ground right so
so you can't fight with someone who's
better at fighting than you and so
instead of
being aikido first my new and current
approach is to be context first and the
context is someone's better at fighting
than you can be at fighting what do you
do to physically deal with them when
they want to fight you well one we don't
get in a fight with them there's number
one right so what if that's off the
table well we keep our distance from
them as best we possibly can well what
if they can
bring the distance down well we try to
state angles where they can't hurt us
and suppress them in some way until we
can get away or help can arrive or
whatever right or we use a weapon right
so those are basically the answers that
you're going to use so
aikido has all those answers and it's
nicely outlined in aikido for aikido but
i think if you're a modern person
thinking about this it's a really clunky
way to kind of learn this so um i'm i'm
kind of teaching a a different way to
learn aikido now and and i would even be
hesitant to say it's aikido it's simply
my approach at this point that i'm
teaching my approach to the context
which you're going to get the same
answers as i could and i you know if if
i showed it and said hey this is chris
heinfuh or something and someone said
well it looks just like aikido i'd say
well of course it does because aikido
had all these answers and so there's
only so many answers to this context
however what's different is the way i'm
organizing it and and building it into a
context for people who don't already
know aikido or don't care about aikido
because a lot of people don't care about
aikido and so the context is still good
whether you care about ikea or not